let's go back to the
witch we're on island again we're back
to the island
and uh let's let's go to the island
let's let's uh i live on an island
it's everything is an island in some
context
like earth is an island this universe is
an island in a multiverse
um there's only one universe all right
so
so let's invite jordan peterson to this
island you wish hold on
hold on hey girl what you doing
lex lex friedman look him up
lex who yeah i don't know lex says no
big of a following almost there's no
jordan i i i know
i know jordan i know his family actually
through um through jim keller who's his
relative he's an engineer so
uh and i just talked to sam uh
who is perhaps a little bit aligned in
some sense
on your perspective on religion and so
on so let me ask
is there something yes but other things
now
oh sorry sam harris he is on first name
relationship with these guys
[Laughter]
i'm just a natural language processing
model
that i assume that once i mentioned
jordan peterson it becomes an
obvious statement what sam means this is
how neural networks think this is how
robots think michael you should know
this
um i thought by now you'd be a scholar
for the sake of the audience humility
everything can teach you something even
a robot
okay so uh do you think there is value
in religion or broader do you think
there's value in
myth in this we've been talking about
the value of reason
do you think it's possible to argue in
society as we grow this
the population of our little island that
there's some value of common myths of
common stories of common religion
there was value there is no value today
so human beings need explanations right
they need a philosophy to guide their
life they need ethics they need
uh some explanation of what's going on
in the world right and there's
there's no accident that the early
religions had a river god and they had a
a a sun god and a moon god because they
they everything they didn't understand
they made god right so so they had
multiple gods because they didn't
understand very much
as human understanding evolved it
increased
as we knew reality more right we we came
to the conclusion of
you know this is very inefficient to
have all these gods this is a genius of
judaism right
let's just have one bucket to put all
the stuff we don't know it and we'll
call it one god
and then we don't as we gain new
knowledge we can just take it out of the
bucket that's god and put it into the
bucket of science
at some point though um at some point
and that point
suddenly came during the scientific
revolution i think uh
we could come to the conclusion that no
uh we don't need this bucket that's
called god to explain the things that we
don't know
we can say we don't know and uh and
we're learning and slowly the our
knowledge is increasing and yet there's
a lot more that we don't know
but we don't need to throw it into some
bucket that's called god in order to in
order to have it
and i think that's true for morality and
it's true for everything else right
as we gain the tools to understand what
morality requires we don't need
a set of commandments we can figure out
morality from human nature and from
reality
so so i don't think we need religion
anymore
i think i think religion needed to die
probably about 200 years ago
and and was dying i think up until kant
it was
it seemed to be dying and one of khan's
missions as he says is to revive
religion uh
against attack of reason and
enlightenment now mythology is a little
different because it depends what you
mean by mythology
certainly we need stories and certainly
we need art
art is a and rand writes about this a
lot and
you know she's an artist and she writes
in i i'm a huge fan of the romantic
manifesto which i think is one of her
underappreciated uh masterpieces oh i
hate it
okay yeah okay yeah so it's i think i
think we have a
real need right as a conceptual being
we have a need for aesthetic experiences
we have a need to
concretize abstractions to concretize
abstract ideas to concretize
the complex nature of the world out
there and that's what painting sculpture
it to some ex to an extent music but
painting sculpture literature does
for us so to the extent that mythology
serves that purpose
it's it's just odd right to the extent
that it serves another purpose that is
that it's
it's a it's a way for the gods to
communicate with us so it fits some kind
of
pre-existing mental construct that we
has again kind of a conscient
perspective right
that we have these categorical
comparatives and these this
mr the this this mythology links up to
that
then i think it's it's it's it's it's
false it's it's
it's not helpful and destructive so i
believe religion today
is a destructive force on planet earth i
think it's always been a destructive
force
it was just a necessary force right you
needed an explanation
people needed something to believe in
once you get philosophy and once you get
philosophy that starts explaining
real life real world you don't need
religion anymore and indeed it becomes a
destructive force and you look around
the world today
it's an unbelievably destructive force
everywhere it touches is
is is uh is bad for life uh again
mythology
depends art is essential very very
crucial for human existence i mean i'd
love to hear what you think
but you don't see religion and
philosophy and mythology
on the is as just a continuous spectrum
yeah so religion is a primitive form of
philosophy
i i don't see philosophical where i
thought with
euron was going to go and he didn't go
was that i think um
he i agree with what he's going to say
rand was
a mythologizer in a certain specific
context atlas shrugged as a myth it's
one thing
to sit down and say these are the people
who move us forward
these are the values that are important
when you experience it through a story
through a movie through a tv show a poem
or a painting
it affects you in a very visceral
very different way talk about american
history you have the founding fathers
then you have the myth of the founding
fathers now the unfortunate term myth
often means lie
but it could mean in a in a useful sense
an abstraction to help you systematize
and concretize ideas
so you have the myth of reagan you have
the myth of thatcher these you know
the reality often falls very short but
when you look at how these different
figures are mythologized
not only is it very inspirational on a
personal level
very motivating on a personal level it's
also a great way
to concretize ideas because just how
humans think it's one thing think about
ideas
but when you see someone who embodies
these ideas miss america you know i was
saying earlier i had an asteroid in my
show
these people might be jerks but when you
look at them one specific aspect of
their life and you extrapolate it
that can be to anyone very motivating
and it's very important
for people to have the belief that
happiness and achievement is possible
because it's very hard to keep that in
mind especially if you're depressed if
you're anxious you're unemployed you
don't have a girlfriend you think it's
gonna be like this forever
and then you look at someone's story and
they're like you know what that asteroid
interview clayton anderson
he applied 13 times didn't get a call
back
applied the 14th time got a call back
didn't get the job 15th time if you get
the job he talks to kids
and he goes listen apply 13
times even if you don't get the call
back you'll still feel
i'm doing something and having heard him
and the myth
of clayton anderson this is going to
tell people yeah you know what that
could be me
you don't think absolutely and and it's
not just happiness it's it's
it's the fact that virtue works yeah the
integrity
i mean what what's the power of the
phone head i know you love the fountain
part of the power the fountain head is
how it works absolute
uh commitment to integrity he is
committed to integrity and he gets any
and he's happy right and and it's very
rare in life
to see that uh to actually share
concrete of that
and it's very hard to hold it in your
mind yes i i'm gonna
be stuck in the quarry or i'm gonna be
stuck doing this horrible job but
if i stick to my principles i'm going to
be i would work now i've got that
concrete i know
i can i can immediately relate to that
success
so i think art is essential and i think
in a sense what we do to thatcher and
reagan is odds you have to be careful in
true stories
not to diverge too far from reality
because then when you discover the
reality you don't want to whitewash it
and particularly when it has
political implications and then it's
really bad so particularly with reagan
at that you have to be careful
because they want anyone near as good as
people tried to make them out to be
but the these these are powerful
powerful powerful stories
and uh and people are moved by and the
integration of emotion
with reason is crucial right one of the
one of the goals to be happy
is to bring your emotions in line with
your thinking
and i think that stories and arts more
broadly and i
you know when i go and see
michelangelo's david it does the same
thing to me
you know i can stand up to anybody
because he did and look he succeeded
and and it makes sense that he could
you